he Kings me on tick tock
[Music]
how does it make you feel to watch him
even now I mean you've seen him a
million times probably right it's always
fun you know being an engineer getting
to make things seeing a tangible result
it's amazing what a life do you also get
to be a creative person you know almost
an artist sometimes well so you've
invented big dog Atlas and Spa out to do
you have a favorite do you feel like a
father figure I mean they all feel like
children they do okay do you think that
humans try to humanize spot you know
most robots including spot are pretty
dumb it's really interesting if you look
on the web when they don't know the
robot or haven't been around it lots of
people fear it or at least they talk
about fearing it but once they're with
it they want to pose for selfies with it
they want to have their kids drive it or
know about it
there are are different case uses for
robots today military for jobs what do
you think are some of the ethical issues
behind that in the future will we have
to worry about Killer Robots or robots
taking over humankind
I think that worry is way overblown and
really a science fiction thing robots
are so limited in their intellect at
this point but I just
you know if it ever happens it's a very
long way off I think there's plenty of
time for us to guard against that kind
of thing really in my mind it's a
balance between the opportunities which
are vast and the risks which I think are
small but some people think are bigger
we're going to try and just assemble
diverse opinions and have a debate
we've been in the robotics industry 45
years so what was that process like and
what really inspired you to create a
robot that can balance you know I was
always a builder even as a kid and then
when I was in graduate school I got a
chance to you know work in a robot lab
and uh one of The Inspirations was when
I went to a conference and saw a robot a
walking robot that was a really slow
mover that had six legs and I just
thought that you know that that we
needed to do better than that six-legged
thing
so you know in the early days we did a
lot of work studying animals filmed
horses and measured how they moved we
looked at animals like ostriches
one of the mottos that our company is
build it break it fix it so rather than
try and work all the time where
everything's working perfectly we go at
it hard you know find the weak spots by
breaking the robot or making it fall
down or whatever it is then you know the
engineers look at what happened and
learn from that and then and then revise
things and move ahead and over the years
we've kind of refined the engineering
learned a lot about how the brains or
the computer has to control the hardware
made much better Hardware but I think
it's possible using some of the progress
that's been being made in artificial
intelligence to make robots that could
watch someone do a task like a
manufacturing task understand what they
were seeing figure out how to do it
themselves and then do it
[Music]
foreign